à des fins de mois
vous détendant
[Musique]
même le
à bientôt porter moi
donc à plus de tomber
[Musique]
merci à la boutique qui me store opéra
de m'avoir gentiment pastis traîneau
mine de tricks trop pour pouvoir en
parler alors aujourd'hui dès l'exercice
et de la boxe et c'est de regarder faire
quelques photos de prendre en main très
rapidement j'aurai les résultats du test
complet d'ici quelques jours
regardez-moi ça ça ça pas mal et en plus
c'est cool c'est qu'ils ont une petite
coptes amis à tout alors je sais pas si
c'est uniquement la boutique à mr opéra
je sais pas du tout en tout cas vous
avez si vous achetez votre smartphone
la petite coque terminator plutôt pas
mal hop un petit smack qu'est ce qu'on a
ici avant d'arriver directement aux
smartphones on a user guide qui écarte
de garantir une petite coque
transparente qui peut avoir un intérêt
bon ok c'est pas mal mais c'est vrai que
tout de suite on préférera cette coque
là qui est quand même vachement plus
cool ça c'est vachement plus cool à ces
résistances à ce puits pas le truc c'est
quoi c'est un espèce dans ça c'est du
plastique et ça c'est quoi ça une espèce
de plastique plus résistants ok ça
marche terminator d'accès it only in
cinéma ok cool ensuite à l'intérieur de
la boîte
le smartphone carte micro sd ou alors
une deuxième nanocyl donc soit vous
mettez de l'inde aussi mme sow vous
mettez une aide aussi une carte microsd
pour l'extension cacoule on est pas mal
c'est ça passe espèce de bleu vert
r un peu entre eux deux avec des reflets
plus noir au milieu beaucoup plus on le
capteur d'empreintes digitales là alors
ça déjà c'est un truc moi je n'aime pas
trop c'est à dire que je vais mettre mon
nom sur un capteur d'empreintes
digitales mais je vais forcément venir
flirter avec le petit capteur ici
dommage parce que ça m'ait laissé des
empreintes de doigts dessus alors après
si je regarde pas là je me tourne je le
sent tout de suite très facilement sous
le doigt je vais pas forcément elle est
trop mais je lequel venir grignoter un
peu là et ça c'est un petit peu dommage
bon quatre modules photo 3 / centre à
son côté le petit flash led 64
mégapixels super cannes arrive de
l'action et artificielle renmibi xiaomi
rewmi affirmé comme une marque à part
entière qui appartient à firmi c'est
plutôt pas mal
à l'avant on a à il est parti que je
préfère rémy 28 pro alors je pense que
vous avez fait gaffe info voit un peu la
64 mégapixels écran de 6 53 pouces est
fatigué plus on a un médiathèque c1 et
lioger 90 t refroidissement liquide
grosse batterie de 4500 millions paire
eur 18 watts de recharges d'encre
recharge rapide ok plutôt cool avant de
continuer à l'intérieur de la boîte on a
le bloc de recharge qui est gros 18
watts est plutôt sympa on a un câble de
recharge directement en usb type c'est
ça c'est cool usb usb tisser des
écouteurs ça c'est obligatoire en france
qui dit écouteurs 10 prises jack tu
voyais écouteurs avec la jac prise jack
micro usb haut parleurs le petit micro
qui est la micro pour la réduction de
bruit qui se situe à la honda de
l'infrarouge petit haut parleur qui est
planqué là on a la petite encoche aurez
deviné l'encoche juste là bouton volume
bouton pour l'allier pour l'éteindre
tiroirs de cartes sim qui situe là mon
design sympa assez pratique assez grand
quand même faut le tenir à demain si
vous voulez venir en haut de l'écran se
voit tout de suite le dos et un peu
glissant je vous conseille quand même de
mettre la coque de protection
d'ailleurs c'est pas mal ce truc et
c'est joli ça c'est une super idée et
ensuite après bond on a fait le tour on
a tous je trouve ça pas mal
après c'est ni ride ni loi il faut aimer
mais après si ça fonctionne plutôt pas
mal ce qu'on va laisser à maintenant
c'est qu'on va aller faire un petit tour
à l'extérieur on va se faire des fautes
on va regarder je le prends toute la
journée avec moi là il est midi 21
je prends avec moi toute la journée ce
soir je fais le débrief global de
première présentera sur une journée mais
ce que j'en pense on fait des photos
on va commencer tout de suite on espère
une petite photo autorise tout pour
l'appareil photo
regardez on peut même faire de la macro
ça a l'air assez cool qu'il photo
souriez acquise voilà petite photo
on se fait un petit reporting et puis on
en reparle dans quelques jours on sait
le test d'ici quelques jours
talgo
17h35 et un verdict après quelques
heures d'utilisation alors j'ai fait
quelques petites photos par ci par là
dans différentes conditions
je vais vous parler que de la photo pour
la france que l'expérience je trouve
assez intéressante mais je me rends pas
vraiment compte plus prendre le temps de
l'utiliser offrir le trouve très
facilement sa place pour le capteur
d'empreintes digitales se déverrouille
assez rapidement je trouve que les
photos tout cas dans l'ensemble bien
assez intéressante
[Musique]
une salade espino souhaite une offre
il nous reçoit
e
je
je m'attendais plus de temps pour
vraiment le prendre en main vous dire ce
que j'en pense pour l'instant c'est
juste une première prise en main est ce
qu'il ya c'est lumière est ce que vous
voyez c'est bien c'est une première
présente je trouve bien le format et un
plus grand si vous aimez les grands
smartphones avec des écrans qui sont
suffisamment grands pour râler du
contenu multimédia 5 semble être en tout
cas intéressant ce qui n'est pas idéal
mais ça c'est pas grave mais c'est sur
ce genre de format là c'est la petite
encoche en eau j'aimerais bien que ses
doigts croches la disparaissent pour
l'aider grand écran à côté de ça c'est
une petite encoche goutte d'eau n'est
pas vraiment problématique l'écran a
l'air d'être plutôt cool les six mois
quelques jours on en parle et je vous
dirai plus en détail ce que j'en pense
en tout cas ce smartphone est assez
prometteur dites moi s'il vous
l'attendez si vous avez hâte s'il vous
plaît si vous l'avez déjà marqué moi
tout ça directement en bas en
commentaire et contre lyon se retrouve
dès demain vous en masse demain ciao